i think a good client has to be  mutually invested in the relationship  and i talk about this as like shared  equity in the process so  if they aren't showing the signs of  commitment they need to to recruit the  right person typically those things fall  down at the end of the process so you  know if i look at our work at the moment  we're probably somewhere in the region  of 65 70 retained at the moment as a  business i know what people will say  because typically our work is 60k plus  and people will say that that's an easy  market to retain we've also started  doing 50 40k rolls retained as well  because if someone wants to recruit  someone and i just think of this from my  own perspective i retain a business in  manchester that does all of our  recruitment for us and  no problem if i'm gonna hire someone  then it's the same fee it's just  structured in a slightly different way  that gives everyone equitable value in  the process  [Music]